相信很多人都听出了最近大火的故事版
可以用尽可能少的抽卡次数生成大片
情绪短片
奉选打斗
或者电商视频
但只要你一实操就会发现
事情并没有那么简单
第一镜的视频还好
但是到了后面
人物开始变化
画风也开始突变
单个画面都还凑合
但是组合起来根本不像一条视频
那今天这期视频
我就保母级带大家学会
怎么用故事版生成一条
稳定有节奏
有空间关系的AI短片
而且这期不只讲概念
都会把实操里最容易翻车的细节
全部讲清楚
看完这期视频
从此你就是故事大师
那所有的提示词和步骤
也都放到文档啦
故事版简单来说
就是在真正生成视频之前
先把一条视频拆分成一组连续的画面
像电影里的分镜草图
也是AI视频的施工图
比如你想做一个白天打斗的场景
如果你只写一个人在训练场打斗
第一镜可能还在训练场
第二镜场景就变了
第一镜人物穿黑衣服
第三镜服装又变了
三张呢
看着都挺燃
但放在一起根本就不像同一场戏
但如果你做成了故事版
AI就有了画面参考
镜组一
白天训练场远景
主角站在场地中央
镜组二
对手从右侧冲过来
主角侧身躲开
镜组三
主角抓住对手手腕
顺势把人带天
镜组四
两人在训练场中央连续过招
动作的节奏很快
镜组五
主角抓住机会反击
对手后退停住
镜组六
主角站稳身体
整理袖口
战斗结束
这就是故事版
故事版就是把脑子里的视频
以前拆成一张一张
能够执行的镜头画面
这样呢
AI就不会乱生成了
不仅节约时间
还能减少我们
反复抽卡消耗的点数
经过测试下来
GBT的Image 2模型的质量
是相对更加理想的
我们只需要填写这段提示词
即可生成我们想要的故事版
不过细心的朋友
肯定发现了
我的故事版是手绘的
这就是实操中
才会遇到的小细节
我们的分镜
只是告诉AI
要生成什么样的镜头
以及台词
如果信息太多
AI反而有可能参考错误
所以我们必须加入
额外的人物参考图
和场景参考图
这样整个视频才不会跑偏
那参考生图也很简单
入入我写的这段提示词结构
就可以直接得到了
现在我们有了故事版
人物参考图和场景参考图
只需要把它们一起喂给AI
再输入这段提示词
就可以生成这样的视频了
但是在实操的过程中
你还会遇到一个问题
有些角度我们怎么生成都不对
或者有些画面的人物还是会乱跳
这时候就要用到我们的终极大招
导演台
学会导演台以后
酷炫打斗
多人物对话
你聊几点
六点半
那倒睡
要打摇了啊
群向镜头
这些以前最容易翻车的镜头
都会稳定很多
不要觉得导演台听起来很专业
其实它的逻辑非常简单
先搭一个场景再把人物放进去
然后就像搭积木一样
调整人物的位置
方向
动作和镜头角度
以前你只能用文字告诉AI
主角站在左边
对手从右边冲过来
但AI不一定能理解左边是哪边
距离有多远
人物该面向哪里
而导演台可以直接把这些关系摆出来
操作也很简单
我们可以使用各种在导演台功能的AI软件
这里就用我常用的软件举例
操作逻辑其实都差不多
首先上传我们生成的场景图
注意这里一定要上传空场景
因为导演台要先建立空间
如果你的场景图里已经有人
后面摆放人物的时候就会很混乱
上传好场景之后
点击上方的720全景
这时候场景就会变成一个可以左右查看的全景空间
接着双击画布先建导演台
点击下方的全景图历史记录
选择刚刚生成的全景图
到这一步我们就成功把人物模型和场景结合起来了
你可以让人物靠左一点或者靠右一点
站在前景或者站在远处
你也可以调整人物朝向
让他面对镜头
侧面对镜头或者背对镜头
还可以点击下方
添加角色
添加各种类型的人物模型
我们可以把人物放进任意场景的任意位置
然后点击截图
生成一个个分镜位置参考图
你看这时候每个镜头的空间关系都非常清楚
AI就不需要再猜
然后呢输入这段提示词
让他参考我们的分镜来生成视频
这样再复杂的画面和人物关系
也可以用这种方式轻松搞定
所以你会发现真正让AI视频稳定出片的
从来都不是花大价钱抽卡
而是你有没有先把整套方法搭好
故事版解决的是镜头顺序和人物关系
人物参考图解决的是人物一致性
场景参考图解决的是场景统一
而导演台解决的是最难控制的空间关系和人物调度
当你把这几步都跑通以后
你做AI视频就不再是碰碰运气
而是像真的导演一样在控制一条片子
不管你做的是情绪短片
酷炫打斗
多人对话
还是更复杂的群像调度
都可以用这套方法先把镜头拆清楚
再把人物和空间稳定住
最后再让AI去丝滑执行
我是AI界人民教师一番
关注我学习更多AI干货